[Music]
what was it really like being married to
Chris Pratt Anna Faris tells all in a
new book just a couple of months after
the breakup look let's be honest that
split was a shocker everything seems so
perfect in their world so we pored
through every single word in the book
for some insight into their failed
marriage and where their relationship
stands today during the decade or so
that Chris and I were together we were
happy and in love and we really are just
regular goofballs
revelation number one anna has put her
eight-year marriage to Chris into the
past tense on admits she made minor
re-edits to unqualified in the wake of
their split but she still dedicates the
memoir to him - Chris your wisdom and
strength have made me a better person
revelation number two Chris wrote the
heartfelt forward after their separation
however he did not lend his voice for
the audible version when I was asked to
write the foreword I immediately said
yes without even thinking about it and
boy did a lot happened between then and
now so much like so much revelation
number three Anna was embarrassed in
hurt when false tabloid reports of an
affair between Chris and his passengers
co-star Jennifer Lawrence made the
rounds Jennifer and I really are
friendly and she was apologetic even
though she didn't need to be because she
hadn't done anything wrong
revelation number four Hana describes
the set of this summer's over board
remake as her sanctuary while it may
sound dramatic to say that it changed me
I really did
ét was on the bank Hoover set in June it
was just one month before the couple
officially announced their split it's
been the best filming experience of my
life there really has
[Music]
you